Merry Christmas boys and girls I'm Santa
Christ and it's certainly yeah hmm maybe
if the director wrote a better script
says it maybe of the actor could just
memorize the lines such a christ has a
lot of work to do little boy he doesn't
have time for silly cameos it's a
blessing that he's here in the first
place
oh but this has nothing to do with that
story
this is the story about the list the
books upside down then the noise is such
a crisis because he's a little OCD that
way book should be right side up I don't
care if it's a prop
it should be right Santa calm yourself
no book should be not like bellman out
thank you
Santa was German that's true and he
never shows up on the Jewish hop in it
I'm gonna be confident para like a cat
oh now you're Jewish oh why must you
turn this character into an anti-semite
but credit you can't believe it excuse
me critic but what else you didn't hear
me hi you still here text yes I'm still
here action
hey people
welcome back to then Cara after dark
today on our guest spot we have asked
that guy with the glasses hello
we're gonna do things that go beyond
your wildest nightmares now that should
be everything but here have an extra
hundred for your troubles hey Lindsey so
um based upon my watch that doesn't
exist we have this friendship based upon
mutual respect and dignity we have the
residents of the one you call angry job
angry Joe hello pipsqueak one behavior
keep it come on these can't possibly be
as bad as Joel being president United
States statue critic I remember it so
you don't have to you're an asshole
it's a wonderful thrill like thrill one
this is difficult people Oh
now kiss and make up
that's right you can't
I don't know how I could have done all
this without you Oh God you wore my
number one angel I don't know how I
could have done all this without you oh
you're my number one
angel god damn it start acting like it
take care of buddy take care you too
alright hey good thing going out now
don't you mean what with the white Rover
the phony T okay no no I'm actually
feeling a lot better
I just need to have this horrible carpet
sneeze alright hey guys I'm back and I'm
here to say hey it's day I fuck this
whole shot up and we've got to do it
again let's go let's go Fargo
Wow that's really interesting giggle
let's see get out your blow me blow me
blow me hmm
blow me that that was my day
thirteen